hello ladies and gentlemen
you find yourself at the end of this
European Council and this euro zone summit
a few words perhaps to
report on our work first we
had a meeting which allowed us to take
stock of the  Ukraine after having listened
by videoconference to President Zelinski
to whom we obviously reaffirmed
our support to help him
win the conflict in the face of
Russian aggression, we will tirelessly continue our
efforts on all political,
military, economic and humanitarian levels
for as long as necessary  I
would particularly like to emphasize on this subject
the importance of the agreement
that we reached in Europe for
the supply to Ukraine of the munitions
and missiles it needs
during our extraordinary European Council
of February 9 and during
its  visit to Paris the day before, the
Ukrainian president had in fact expressed
urgent needs in this area and
European work began
immediately and resulted less than six
weeks later in a very
robust system which includes three components which
will be implemented in a manner
simultaneous coordinated and which we have
taken action at our level in the very short term
we will accelerate deliveries to
Ukraine of ammunition and missiles of
all types available in the stocks of the
Member States
to replace its equipment we
will at the same time set up a
system  joint acquisition of
munitions and missiles from
the European defense industry,
particularly through
the European Defense Agency, and the
European funding that we will
provide will be used to purchase European goods
and at the same time
European defense industries  will benefit from
increased support from the European Union to
strengthen their production capacity,
secure
supply chains and promote
access to investments and,
following on from what we agreed
at Versailles a year ago, we must
indeed give us the means to build
a war economy at the
European level as we do at the
national level and therefore this aspect is in my
eyes a very important point of the work
of the last few weeks and which we have
completed during this summit our
discussion has  also allowed us to reaffirm
our determination to fight against
impunity for crimes committed in
Ukraine
obviously supporting
international jurisdictions in this matter and
denounced the abominable kidnappings and
forced deportation of children to
Russia in which you saw it we
have  decided to take a collective initiative
I would also like to
point out that we wanted to discuss
the situation in Moldova and as I
had the opportunity to say to President
Maya Sandouv last Friday we
will continue to support
Moldova in its  European path and to
help it face the numerous
destabilizations as well as the consequences
of the war precisely in Ukraine and
we in the coming weeks will
present a support plan for
Moldova also in anticipation of the summit of
the European political community which will be
held  at kishy now next June 1st
the second major subject of this council
was the economic situation of our
union and as I told you
last December we had given ourselves
the first quarter of this year to
provide a response to American Lyra and
to build a coherent collective strategy
and basically
what the Commission was able to do and I
really want to congratulate it was
able to be debated and approved by the
council it is this law on the
net 0 industry which responds well  to the needs of a
shock of simplification and
modernization for the most
important sectors for the
energy and climate transition
this text will allow us to facilitate
investments to simplify
the installation of new projects to
strengthen skills to better
coordinate our aid and  “experimenting
with more flexible and
more adapted regulations will also allow us to
better integrate
environmental and security
of supply criteria into our
public procurement. In total, this is a key element
of our technological sovereignty in
decarbonization
in terms of aid.  State in this regard
we also have concrete progress
to support our strategic industries more and better
and adapt the
framework that was ours we
finally had an exchange on the other
components of the long-
term competitiveness of our union such as
public investments  and private
ambitious research the training and
standards that we need as you
know we have constantly
defended an
ambitious and common industrial policy the agenda
of strategic autonomy which was
at the heart of the Versailles summit
last year thus finds  to decline and
between the chips acts
this regulation on the net 0 industry
and the regulation on
critical raw materials and
rare earths we have a set of
industrial policies and preservation
of our sovereignty which marks in my
eyes not simply an awakening in  terms
of doctrine but a concrete action of
our Europe to face the
recomposition of the world with
geopolitical risks and which marks a real
start
speaking of competitiveness of
industrial policy we obviously
mentioned the energy subjects which
constitutes a fundamental aspect
of both  our competitiveness and our
sovereignty and our strategy in the face
of climate change in this regard
first of all we have demonstrated our desire
to make full use of the instruments with which we
have equipped ourselves we are emerging from
winter in a position which is
better than  it was not expected by
market players a few
months ago we resisted and we
still have stocks which are fuller
than many
experts thought we
now have to use our
joint purchasing capacities  to prepare for
next autumn and winter in a
geopolitical and international context which
will not be simpler than
last year but we have the means
and we now have the instruments
the second thing is the reform of the capital
market  electricity so that the
prices paid by consumers are
more correlated to the production costs of
carbon dioxide, which means more
stable and lower prices in this regard,
regulation is moving forward and we have
agreed today to adopt this
reform before the end  of the year with
therefore the adapted accelerated procedure
above all this European Council was
the opportunity for a strategic discussion
on the place that we wish to
reserve for nuclear power in our
European energy policy the
Presidency of the Commission recalled
with great clarity the  state of our
ambitions in terms of decarbonization and
the rational path to achieve them
obviously there are
renewable energies and France is investing
massively for their deployment and
at the same time we have set
objectives for decarbonization and
security of our production
of  electricity and to achieve them
we know that renewable cannot be
enough and that nuclear power
constitutes a necessary part of the
response at European level both
in our energy mix and to
produce low carbon hydrogen tomorrow,
it is moreover  which corresponds to
the very spirit of our treaties, respecting
everyone's energy mixes but
preserving a principle of
technological neutrality enshrined in the
European treaties. We have found this
balance in the European taxonomy
by recognizing the role that
nuclear power had to play and  This is the
spirit that the President of the
European Commission recalled during
this council and that several
member states including France defended,
so you see there is a very
long discussion which ended very
early for a European council yesterday  evening
but which made it possible to address these major
subjects of industrial policy and
strategic autonomy of
energy policy and the coherence of a
commercial policy which must
continue to advance in being an
open Europe but while
obviously preserving standards  protectors
for our agriculture and our
industry and I was able to recall in this
regard that if new
trade discussions were to be reopened or
reactivated, France would defend two
essential elements: on the one hand,
respect for the Paris agreements and our
commitments in terms of  climate and
biodiversity and on the other hand
mirror clauses because we would be asked of our
farmers or our industrialists to make
efforts in terms of norms and
standards which would not be required of the
producers to whom we
would open our markets
this morning during the  euro zone summit
we took stock with the
president of the European Central Bank
on the situation of the
banking sector outside our borders
the fundamentals of European banks
are solid and we can
welcome the high standards of our
regulations  on this subject we have
learned from past crises and I want to
say that the euro zone is today the
zone where the banks are the most
solid because they have
most scrupulously followed the banking ratios
of solvency and liquidity which
have come out  of the financial crisis of
2008-2010 this context must simply
encourage us on the one hand to accelerate the
construction of the Banking Union and the
Capital Markets Union to
have a European Union and a
euro zone which is aligned  savings and which
is precisely more solid in terms of
financing its activities and on top
of that having a
macroeconomic strategy adapted to the context, this is
why we support the
proposals made by the
European Commission precisely in terms of
economic governance which seems to me
be a key point in this regard finally I
would like to conclude by welcoming
the agreement reached on March 18 between
Serbia and Kosovo under the aegis of the High
Representative it is a significant step forward
it is essential that the
two parties now demonstrate
responsibility by
immediately implementing both good
faith all of their obligations
under the agreement we remain mobilized
in this sense you know how much
Germany and France are working
together on this subject and we will
continue to do so  I will
now answer your questions
hello
is it not a
total humiliation that France cannot
guarantee the security of Her Majesty for
this initial visit scheduled for Monday
thank you for your question which allows me
to clarify things  and basically to
provide a common sense response
I believe that you see the situation
linked precisely to the protests
due to the pension reform in
France from the moment when last night
the inter-union announced a new
day of mobilization  Tuesday and the
king's visit was planned from Monday to
Wednesday I think that we would not be
serious and we would lack a
certain common sense proposed to His Majesty
the King and the Queen that we go out to come and
make a visit to  State in the middle of the
demonstrations and therefore as we have
a lot of friendship of respect of esteem
for His Majesty the King and the Queen
Consort and for the British people
I took the initiative this morning to
call him and to  to say what the
situation was from the moment when there
was this day which had been decided
common sense and friendship lead us
to propose a postponement which was
detestable
for the British people as for
ourselves it is on the contrary
that we are trying to maintain as if
nothing had happened with incidents at
stake so we have to organize that when
calm returns and therefore we
proposed that at the beginning of the summer
depending on our respective agendas we
could together
new state visit which
corresponds both to the way of
properly receiving
the new king and the queen consort and of
doing so in conditions which
will allow him to benefit from France
Paris as Bordeaux I myself will be
present at his invitation to  coronation ceremony
hello Julien gasparuto France
Télévision to extend the question of
my British comfort you were
expressed on Wednesday and since then we have witnessed
a renewed mobilization of violence
obviously your message and Malpassé
we have just talked about it you are obliged to
postpone  the arrival of King Charles III
is today the street that
dictates your agenda are you
prevented from governing this is
a question that we have also heard
in foreign delegations  since the
beginning of this summit thank you thank you for your
question I do not believe at all first of all there is
a democratic path on pension reform
which must
continue it is the work of the
Constitutional Council and its decision and
then the rest of the  work besides
I will note like you that Parliament
continued to function that on energy
we had a vote in the assembly that
on the Olympic and Paralympic Games
the text of the law continued to progress
that I asked the  Prime Minister
the content of progress that in the
coming days we will announce our
water strategy and therefore
in accordance with what I was able to explain
to the French on Wednesday we continue to
move forward the country cannot be at
a standstill  we have lots of challenges
first of all to deal with emergencies
next summer's drought and the
water shortages that we are experiencing are
a way to continue reforming the
labor market and allowing us to continue
creating jobs  in our country is
another what we have to do in
terms of
improving our
security we are also another the
military programming law which will
arrive so we have an agenda it will
continue to advance and then
protests  who are there in the
face of the violence that I distinguish from the
demonstrations we will also continue to
have the greatest firmness and therefore on
this subject I condemn the violence
that we witnessed yesterday
I call on everyone to take responsibility and
I assure the forces of my support  of
order who have done an exemplary job
for the rest we continue to move forward
the country deserves it and we need it
the secretary general of the CFDT Laurent
Berger calls on the government to put
the pension reform in pause mode
as he has  formulated and immediately initiated
negotiations with the unions on
working conditions on the end
of careers on the employment of seniors it
also asks that the inter-union
be received as soon as possible at the Élysée
what is  you respond to this
proposal first I thank Laurent
Berger for his spirit of responsibility
and his desire for appeasement which I
share then I myself on Wednesday
indicated our availability to move forward
on subjects such as
professional wear and tear the ends  career
retraining
career development
working conditions remuneration in
certain branches and therefore I am
totally available as well as the
government to move forward
immediately on these subjects and therefore I
am at the disposal of the
union land if it wishes  come and
meet me to move forward on all these
subjects for the rest and the
pension reform it is before the
Constitutional Council and it is obvious that
we will wait for the decision of the Constitutional Council
I am therefore available and willing
to move forward on these important subjects
for our  compatriots hello Mr.
President Mathieu Desmoulins for TF1
LCI I remain on social mobilization
the end of the demonstration yesterday you
said it reached a new milestone in terms of
violence are not particularly and we saw
these images of the town hall door  of
Bordeaux which was set on fire, how do
you react to this scene
and then on the other side of the
law enforcement system we have seen many
videos of inappropriate behavior on
the part of members of the security forces
?  order is that in recent days
on maintaining the security of
demonstrations the use of force has
always been proportionate thank you
it is always a difficulty when there are
moments of very high tension
that they are subject to our  forces of
law and order
and therefore I thank the Minister of
the Interior and Overseas Territories, the prefect
of police
and all of his colleagues for the
very clear messages that have been sent
calling for order and for full
and respectful respect.  entire ethics
and the support that I provide to the
police force has, if I may say with it,
embarked a requirement with regard to the
latter they know it now I have
especially seen scenes where many of our
police officers  our gendarmes were
the object of totally
disproportionate aggression on the part of
extraordinarily violent and equipped activists who
are clearly preparing
demonstrations of this type in Sainte Soline for the
coming days with
equipment of rare violence already
seized by our  security forces
we will not give in to this violence
nothing in democracy we do not have the right to
violence and therefore full respect for
ethics is required of
our police forces with the
transparency which must go behind and
examination but I do not put it in
parallel with what is happening in
society we do not give in to
violence and I condemn it with the
greatest firmness
hello Fabienne Schmitt daily Les
Échos
a question on the banking crisis I
have  noted that you had said that the
fundamentals of European banks
were
solid, since this morning we have nevertheless seen
a fall on the stock market of Deutsche
Bank which brings in its wake a
certain number of other
European banks including Société Générale.  we
should not see this as a form
of contagion of the setbacks linked to Crédit
Suisse and what responses
can Europe provide? I imagine that it
was a question of it, we talked about it, I
think that what is happening is quite
clear,
we are  in a very
different situation because we have
demanding regulation in the euro zone with
very high transparency of the ratios
which are closely monitored and a requirement
moreover which has placed on our
banking systems significantly higher than what we
have been able to experience in the  United States of America
in other banks one of the problems of
Crédit Suisse being its
exposure to certain American assets
as you know
so we are not in a
comparable situation the fundamentals
are healthy and that is what  moreover
in the past may have cost the euro zone
because we have been more demanding
of ourselves so when the
crisis is here we must recognize where
our strengths are then what is happening
is speculators who are
attacking the CDS which are in the process of
testing with today an impact this
morning an impact on the equity markets
I believe that on this we must
know how to distinguish
speculative behavior and actors who seek
to make money  short-term money and
fundamentals which remains healthy under
solid supervision which has in
recent years demonstrated its robustness
yes go ahead do
n't want to ratify it we can't
continue did you talk about it
today among yourselves is it  that you
have the feeling that this wants to move forward
quickly or are we still
in a stuck situation and to
complete you spoke of speculation
but
the rise in rates which we know
weakens the banks and even if even before
they have good fundamentals it
can still weaken them even if
the banking supervision is good so does
that worry you a little
then on your second question no
it is the role of the European Central Bank
but today the
monetary normalization policy which is ours is not
likely to create problems for our
European banking system or for our
players obviously we had
a previous situation where the rates
as you know the policy was
extremely exceptional so
on that  I repeat, the fundamentals are
there and it is not this policy of
monetary normalization which in
any way threatens the fundamentals of
our banking system whether it is
their solvency or their liquidity
then you are right to say that
the Banking Union is not progressing
fast enough, however, the part which is
important in situations like the one
we are currently experiencing
has been done is the one which allows
common supervision the one which allows
interventions on the
actors we must now go to the end
on the question of deposits and the
elements of solidarity in Europe,
France's desire is to support
this path and I hope that where, as
you said, several Member States
are hesitant  see have not found an
agreement we can find it as
soon as possible France is not
the blocking element nevertheless I want to
say here that the part of the
Banking Union which was made
our structuring in terms of
supervision
and the quality of the players and their
credibility on the markets make I
believe our system very solid
today
hello ani anus balm from Bloomberg news
you therefore mentioned the Union the
European Union and deposits the guarantee of
common deposits to what  deadline
can we manage to put this project back
on the workbench and second question on
Franco-German relations what
was the reception of this is what you
were able to say about nuclear power and
the importance of nuclear power in  the
decarbonization of the economy what opinion do
you have of this German proposal
to give an exemption for
If Younes from 2035 and then
what was the content of your
exchanges this morning at breakfast with
the German chancellor then
I am not the master of the clocks for
European negotiations or France
is not the country which today opposes
elements blocking our wish to
all and this was reaffirmed with great
force and the president of the
president keeps it there  said it is a
necessity today to accelerate this
movement
and you know it is a necessity to
complete the Banking Union but above all
we must go as far as the
Capital Markets Union why because
in the  macroeconomic context that is
ours
we need to accelerate the proper
financing of private actors we can
see it clearly we need to invest
faster on the climate transition
to invest faster on defense
to invest faster on all
elements of transition and we have
global competition there is a question of
public money but above all a big
question of private money and the
Capital Markets Union is what makes it possible
to properly allocate savings between
sectors and geographies or
today what is not optimal
within the European Union and
particularly the euro zone is
that in fact we have a lot of savings we have
the capacity to finance but it
is not  well allocated between zones
and sectors
and completing the Capital Markets Union
serves that purpose so it is really
the time to do it for our
common interest in European growth and
our ability to create jobs in
the  context that is ours so we are
really defending an acceleration
of this work because it is relevant
and I hope that we will succeed in
convincing the most hesitant then
we have a very good discussion this
morning with the chancellor who told us
allowed first of all to come back to the
elements of technological neutrality
it is not so much in the discussion that
we had there as in the texts which
are discussed by our ministers with
technical aspects I think that we
will find the agreement we are in the process
to find it on hydrogen like
other subjects to preserve
technological neutrality and allow
what I believe is an objective shared by
all which is to decarbonize our
economy and by decarbonizing it to be able to
meet our climate objectives and
to maintain both  competitiveness and
sovereignty
nuclear and renewable energy allows
the use
of everything that is
coal or gas does not allow it so
we have found a way to an agreement and
I think that we will be able to move forward in
the coming days and
weeks on this  direction
then I will also be very clear
with you on the famous issues there is
no German request to call into
question the agreement that we have for 2035
there is simply a will there too
within the framework of this agreement  to be able to
preserve fuel oils as was in
fact in our declaration
a year ago and therefore the
Chancellor was very clear on the fact
that this does not call into question the
2035 European objective of having  vehicles without
CO2 emissions,
that's our objective so we are
sticking to it and in this context without reopening
the trilogue to be able to find the
technical modalities to provide the
answer to what we had declared
together so there is no disagreement
on this  subject between us and there is a
desire to move forward, especially to support
our manufacturers in this transition
which is very ambitious and which is
obviously important for the climate
but which is very demanding for our
industries and for all the workers
in this sector and therefore  we must
support them with investment and
stability
are there any other questions I
still have two go ahead and then
sir
scene of
very strong violence last night is-
what you fear is that the
maple movement is leaving the control of the unions
a bit like the yellow vests that we
saw and another question on China I
believe that you raised it with your
counterparts do you  have talked about it
in a concrete way you are talking about you are
leaving in ten days for China are
you leaving with a mandate or
perhaps not just a unified position
in relation to Russia and their relationship
I have the feeling I have answered  already to
your first question on the second
question
so China it is not a question of having a
mandate France is a sovereign country
which has its own diplomacy but I
am committed to being coordinated to bring
a European voice it is for
We raised the subject this morning with
Chancellor Scholtz
and we have a common view which is
to try as much as possible to involve China
alongside us to put pressure on
Russia not to obviously use
chemical weapons and
nuclear weapons but also to
do everything to stop the conflict, return to
the negotiating table and
enable international law to be respected,
that is to say the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
Ukraine,
then we have a
European position  which was defined
several months ago on which we are
sticking
and that is also why I offered
to the president to accompany me on
part of this segment of the visit
as I had the opportunity  to do it
during the president's state visit to
Paris a few years ago by
involving Chancellor Merkel and
President Juncker at the time to have a
united path and so that is what we
will do during this  this visit to China
I will perhaps take one last
question sir
there
but it is the president during your
meeting with George Meloni did you
learn of your differences in particular on the
question of immigration
and share with you the Italian analysis
according to  which the collapse
of Tunisia a camera a
humanitarian disaster we had a very good
discussion with the president of the council
Meloni yesterday evening which made it possible to
clarify many subjects to define
an effect of the paths on which we
can move forward together on the
European bilateral plan I think that it is
our responsibility
in this context we have indeed mentioned
the situation in Tunisia or
the very great political tension the
economic and social crisis which is raging in
the still absence of agreement with the
International Monetary Fund and very
worrying it leads first of all to a
crisis for Tunisia itself a very
great destabilization of the country in the
region and indeed an
increased migratory pressure on the line and on
the European Union and therefore our desire
to  'act together to be able to
help Tunisia regain
political stability, we hope
to find an agreement with the International Monetary Fund
and also to initiate
avenues of cooperation, one of the
components of which is the control of
emigration  from Tunisia because it
is very clear that the
primary objective must first be stability and a path of
growth for Tunisia in the
very fragile context in which this country
finds itself, but we must also
succeed in stopping migratory flows in the very short term.
who talk about Tunisia and
who
increase the pressure on Italy
rest of Europe on this subject I
believe that we have
concrete cooperation that we can have
both in the dialogue with the
Tunisian president and his government with the
Fund  International Monetary but also
because we ourselves as a country
can do bilaterally and
with the European Union for Tunisia, thank you
very much, ladies and
gentlemen, welcome back to those
who are returning to their capital and good
luck to the  others